I was watching I think the the first
episode the pilot episode of your show
and I was looking at the the mom no it
was a the mom the woman who plays your
mom on the show yesterday
Jodi long she is she's very funny she
plays a very domineering mother and I'm
wondering is that based on your real mom
in any way it is a caricature of my
mother people are gonna think my mother
is kind of a hardened tiger mom but my
mom is is a soft gentle woman without
with a rough side and you know she's
been so supportive of me over the years
that I actually rewarded her after I was
done with this by taking for her for a
trip around the world right and I
brought some pictures you took your mom
on a trip around the world yeah
to show my love and support for my real
mom that's so cool yeah
you brought photos instead alone that's
the photo you guys want to take a look
take a look this is my mother and I
God's sake you back me moogles no that's
that's just it not really that's you and
I Agri Falls isn't that wonderful let's
let's see the next one
that's Justin that's not at the Vegas
the Vegas one that's the real Paris okay
and then we looked at the funeral of Kim
Jong Il I'm John you know that's didn't
think you'd let people ride on your
shoulders at Kim Jong Il's funeral she's
actually very light woman he was you had
me suckered in you bastard